hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast sample to insight everything
you need to know about RNA sequencing it
is presented by Jonathan Schafer PhD
associate director of next-generation
sequencing
assay technologies at kyochon I am Judy
O'Rourke of leopards and I will be your
moderator for today's offense we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by cryogen for more
information about our sponsor visit wwii
gen calm before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Schaefer I will now turn the
presentation over to him
Thank You T I appreciate the opportunity
to talk with everybody today and again
we'll be discussing everything you need
to know about RNA sequencing
let's begin with our standard legal
disclaimer that cotton products shown
here are intended for molecular biology
applications and these products are not
intended for the diagnosis prevention or
treatment of a disease so we have a
packed agenda today we'll begin with an
RNA focused NGS overview and then we'll
discuss are an extraction library
preparation sequencing analysis and
finish up with a brief discussion about
genomic services a summary of today's
talk and then we'll go into any
questions that you have
so first off let's take a look at RNA
focused NGS so NGS enables a thorough
investigation of both coding and
non-coding RNAs this is specifically
applied to gene expression pathway
analysis biomarker discovery
allele-specific expression fusion genes
in cancer tumor heterogeneity immune
repertoire as well as single cell
sequencing now of course there's other
applications beyond this but at the
current moment these are more of the
hotter areas of which NGS is involved
with so if you look at the variety of
specific analytes you have the small
guys you have the micro RNAs in the PI
RNA so your twenty to thirty base pair
RNA so you have your T RNAs that are
slightly larger all the way up then to
looking at your long non-coding RNAs and
ultimately your messenger RNAs and
whether you're looking at your micro
RNAs which are the master regulators of
gene expression or your mRNAs you have
are able to apply any of these molecules
to these specific applications
very importantly all our nays are unique
and have individual properties that
matter so your mRNAs are coding they're
approximately two hundred to a hundred
thousand nucleotides they have a five
prime cap their poly a dental ated
there's more than 21,000 human genes and
they have the entire expression range so
very low to very high long non-coding
rnas are different from mRNAs in that
they may or may not have the
polyadenylation site and they also have
very low expression to moderate
expression now micro rna's totally blow
the whole thing up
so they're non-coding they have a
regulatory function but there are only
19 to 25 nucleotides as a result of that
there are specialized library preps that
are made particularly for micro rnas and
very much like their larger friends the
mRNAs and long non-coding RNAs they have
very low to high expression levels and
an overall tip is that the unique
properties of rnase demands specialized
library prep solutions
so when I was putting together this
presentation I came up with this pyramid
so I turned at the pyramid of NGS
success so it starts with a bedrock of
your sample source so if you have a good
sample material or know what type of
sample material you're working with say
you're FFPE samples this lays the
foundation for the rest of your work and
throughout the day's talk we'll work our
way up the pyramid starting with a
sample source ultimately finishing with
analysis
so first off looking at sample types
typically when performing sequencing
your sample types are your fresher your
frozen cells and tissues your FFPE
tissues serum and plasma bio fluids in
general so cerebrospinal fluid bronchial
lavage urine etc and ultimately even
whole blood and our general overall tip
is that we recommend choosing sample
prep kits that provide you with a
flexibility to analyze all RNAs so you
may say well at this point in time why
do you say that all library prep kit
should be created equal as well as all
these sample prep kits as well and the
answer is that some kits still only give
you the option of looking at your longer
RNAs and this isn't the best idea
particularly when you're interested also
in micro RNA so my advice is always make
sure that you pick a prep kit that
allows you to look at both your small
rnas and your long RNA
so this moves nicely now into our second
point of RNA extraction so here at Eisen
we've developed our reputation as the
gold standard for sample prep over years
and years and years so for fresh and
frozen cells and tissues we recommend
the micro and easy kits the micro and
easy kits give you the true total RNA
fraction so everything from your very
small micro rna's to your mRNAs these
come in three flavors the mini of the
micro in the 96 minis for your standard
samples micros for your ultra small
samples and 96 is when you need more
than just your single spin columns you
have an entire plate of samples that you
can do with the micro or an easy 96 kit
we also recommend the RN ez + mini +
micro in the plus 96 as you guessed it
it has the same format so the minis the
micro and the 96 and then ultimately if
you're interested in DNA mrna and micro
RNA we recommend the all prep kit now
for FFP tissues serum and plasma and
exosomes sort of has the same flavor
here so you have the micro an easy FFP
kit in the all prep kit for FFPE for
serum and plasma we have the Heysel
chloroform free solution the micro are
an easy serum plasma advanced kit we
also have our long-running Micronesia
serum plasma kit as well as the kaya amp
circulating cell-free DNA RNA kit this
kit is very nice in that you have both
DNA and RNA in the same Elliott allowing
you to do those multi modal type of
experiments for exosome and Richmond in
isolation we have the XOR an easy kit
both the MIDI kit in the maxi kit and
the choice depends on your input amount
so the MIDI kit gives you up to about
one ml of fluid while the maxi kit
accommodates more than four MLS
stuff over here in the middle is the
packaging kit so you have the packaging
blood kit that allows you to isolate RNA
from whole blood and the tissue kit that
allows you to of course isolate your
total RNA from tissue now a point that's
constantly brought up over the years is
about heparin
so heparin comes into play with your
plasma samples and sadly happen is very
potent reverse transcription inhibitor
and for a long time because of this you
have the inability to use heparinized
samples basically you get the cleanest
library that you can ever imagine
basically because there's no library
there and in response to this we have
developed a solution to remove heparin
from your RNA samples and if you're
interested in this you can ask a
question about this or may you have my
email address through the slides and
feel free to email me and I will send
you the protocol also when you're
looking at sample prep you often need a
variety of instrumentation so we have
the kind of tube HT so this enables you
to process 96-well format samples and in
conjunction with this is the arnie z96
keio tube HT kit for isolation now your
chi a cube this is a 12 sample per run
isolation solution and basically enables
automation of any of the kaijin spin
column kits I like to say that this is
basically an extra pair of hands that
you have in your lab you load your
samples on and ultimately everything is
performed that you get your isolated
nucleic acids for quantification and
quality control of your DNA and RNA
there is the kiya expert the sample
input range is from 1.5 to 2000
nanograms per microliter double-stranded
DNA very nicely there are preloaded apps
for specific isolation kits from kaijin
if you're using isolation kits that are
nitrogen of course
you can still use the kya expert very
nicely to you can assess 16 samples in
only two minutes
now looking at the quality control of
the RNA sample so what actually matters
so when you're looking at concentration
I recommend a standard spec or working
with either fresh or frozen cells and
tissues as well as FFPE samples
and for cymryd plasma I don't recommend
any GC now probably you're like what in
the world is he talking about so we'll
touch on serum and plasma here once we
go through both the purity and the size
distribution so for purity we so this is
your classic two sixty to eighty two
sixty two thirty ratios again we
recommend a standard spec and precise
distribution analysis we recommend the
kiya excel or the bio analyzer the tape
station or the fragment analyzer or
something along those lines and again we
recommend these for cells tissues and
FFPE samples and looking very quickly at
the kiya excel advanced you can assess
the size distribution of up to 96
samples per run and the speed is about
twelve samples or every three minutes
and what you receive from this is an RNA
integrity score or a risk number alright
so back to serum and plasma so why don't
we recommend taking the concentration
assessing the purity or assessing the
size distribution and the reason is that
in serum and plasma they are largely
devoid of ribosomal RNA and typically
speaking ribosomal RNA constitutes more
than 80 percent of the RNA in your
samples and as a result of that when you
don't have ribosomal RNA present your
concentration readings look very low but
in fact they're very much on par with
what you would expect with cells and
tissues if you remove the ribosomal RNA
same thing when the to 60 to 80 to 60 to
30 ratios are derived these are derived
largely looking at the ribosomal RNA so
if you don't have them there your purity
assessment isn't that valid ultimately
when you look at size distribution
typically you're looking at the
integrity of the ribosomal RNA bands and
again without them they're really your
risk number is very low but in fact your
sample quality is probably perfectly
fine
okay so now let's shift gears here again
and discuss library preparation the
first off we'll start to take a look at
a whole transcriptome assessment
so typically whole transcriptome is done
uses using stranded RNA library preps
what does this mean so say you have the
following example you have a chromosome
plus strand and a chromosome minus
strand
gene a is on the plus strand gene B is
on the minus strand and these two
overlap so you have transcript a and
transcript B with this overlapping
region now if you don't perform stranded
RNA seek you don't have any retention of
the transcript orientation so the result
you can't actually see if this is
transcript a or transcript be stranded
RNA say gives you this benefit that the
transcript orientation is retained and
you can say if it's actually a B or both
and just as a tip when you're working
with whole transcriptome analysis our
recommendation is to start with more
than 100 nanograms of total RNA to
reduce the potential for duplicates
Crypton sequencing enrichment or
depletion is often necessary to maximize
your reads from the rnas of interest and
this is because the typical RNA
composition in the cell is more than 80%
ribosomal RNA so if you're interested in
ribosomal RNA this is the perfect
solution if you don't enrich it but of
course most people aren't interested in
specifically ribosomal RNA they're
interested in your mRNAs or your long
non-coding RNAs and as a result you want
to perform either enrichment for your
mRNA or depletion of your ribosomal RNA
to obtain your reads of interest
- what are two styles of strategies so
for poly-a enrichment basically you're
pulling out your mRNAs you're making use
of the fact that mRNAs are
polyadenylated and you basically capture
these polyadenylated RNAs now the one
caveat of this is is that long
non-coding RNAs typically do not have a
poly a tail so as a result if you're
interested in long non-coding RNAs as
well you want to perform ribosomal
depletion and basically what that means
is that you are removing the ribosomal
RNAs and you are left with your mRNAs
and your long non-coding RNAs and the
strategy ultimately depends on what you
want so if you want mRNAs it's fine to
just enrich for those but if you're
interested in mRNAs and long non-coding
RNAs make sure to perform ribosomal
depletion so ties in we have two kits
here we have the high seek stranded mRNA
selected what this kit enables is mRNA
enrichment and subsequent library prep
and we also have a Chi C stranded total
RNA library prep then that can
accommodate samples that have been Rio
de pleated now if you're looking at the
current menu of offerings from kaijin we
do not have a ribosomal depletion kit
listed on the website and the reason is
is because we actually have a brand new
kit launching basically as we speak here
it's called kaya seek fast select and
it's basically a one-step ribosomal
depletion method that key that can be
incorporated into either the kaya seek
stranded library prep kit or any of your
common library prep kits from Lumina any
beat Kappa etc so if you want more
information on the KY seek fast select
kit certainly send me an email or ask a
question about it
so a little more theory here on how
stranded libraries are prepared so
traditionally we have the following
method you have your RNA in your
fragment you then perform reverse
transcription in the presence of a of
actinomycin D which prevents anti sense
reverse transcription from there you
perform second strand synthesis with the
UTP
following and repair you have adapter
ligation so you're like a ting your Y
adapters and then ultimately you have
your library amplification and this is
the basically your second strand is
tagged with the D UTP and this is
degraded and the tagged B UTP strand is
not amplified during PCR so what that
enables you to do is that you can have
strand specificity because you've
basically degraded one of your strands
during library amplification
arrived a stranded library is what we do
with the kaya C kit
so you still fragment your RNA upfront
and you perform reverse transcription
however we use a new method where you do
not have to use X in ax my Cindy in the
second strand synthesis we synthesized
the second strand with normal dntps
instead of D UTP however we use a
phosphorylated
random primer
so then ultimately when we perform our
strand-specific ligation you have this
phosphate on one strand so what this
enables is that you have ligation of
your adapter to this tribe this five
prime end of the fragment this three
prime end of the fragment and this three
prime end of the top strand but the
bottom strand five prime end does not
contain a phosphate and as a result the
adapter arm is not like ated to it what
this means is that during then library
amplification you only have exponential
amplification of one strand and this
enables you in a different manner to
have a stranded library
so looking at a little bit of data of
the Chi Sikh stranded Kip we used the
CQC samples so this is your universal
human reference RNA and the human brain
reference RNA we also did the standard
titrations of three parts to one part
universal human to human brain as well
as one part universal human to three
parts human brain we use the Chi seek
stranded kit as well as competitor T
with sequence this on a high C 2500 we
performed analysis on the CLC biomedical
workbench and in the subsequent slide
you'll see the PCA analysis to view the
overall expression profiles so for
stranded miss here stranded miss is just
again like I was mentioning you want to
know what strand your library prep is
coming from and typically speaking you
want this to be in about 96 or 95
percent above and both the hi-c kit and
competitor T are both in this range so
what it shows you is even though there's
two different ways to derive stranded
miss both basically accomplish their
goal of deriving stranded miss
so now what's fun about the CQC samples
and their titrations are that when you
perform a PCA analysis they group
together in their expected order so
first you have on the end of the PCA
universal human reference RNA and human
brain RNA so when you have three parts
universal human the one part human brain
this is very close to your universal
human reference and when you have one
part universal human to three parts
human brain this is more towards your
human brain and again it's closer
grouped with the you HRR because this is
again a universal human reference RNA so
it's packed with RNA from all types of
tissues so when you overlay the Chi seek
it and competitor T basically everything
is on top of each other so whether
you're looking at universal human
reference the titrations or universal
human brain the samples are on top of
each other so the conclusion that can be
drawn from this is that chi seek and
competitor t demonstrate very similar
strand in this as well as expression
profiles
okay so so now moving beyond the world
of whole transcriptome analysis so
beyond whole transcriptome analysis you
can perform targeted RNA seek or you can
perform qPCR validation but since today
we're talking about sequencing we'll
focus on targeted RNA NGS so why should
you do targeted NGS basically it gives
you the ability to have more relevant
data this is because you are defining
your targeted regions because in whole
transcriptome you have regions that are
basically not of interest to you so
you're able to basically pinpoint what
you want also you have an improved limit
of detection because more Breed budget
is allocated each sample when you're
only focusing on what exactly you need
it gives you an increased confidence in
calling your Louis pression genes tied
with this is that you can multiplex more
samples together so typically speaking
when you're performing a whole
transcriptome analysis if you if you've
poly a enriched you need about 25
million reads per sample
however when performing targeted RNA
seek and say you only are multiplexing
five hundred targets together you need
much less pre-budget for your sample
to the final point why would you perform
kiya seek targeted RNA and yes and
basically because all library amp and
sequencing bias is removed through the
usage of unique molecular indices
straight the principle of unique
molecular indices
so let's take a look at your original
sample so if you look at two genes gene
one has three molecules and gene two has
two molecules giving you a ratio of
three to two so then you perform your
library prep and ultimately your
sequencing and ignoring the small
colored bars for now let's take a look
at the raw reads so after you perform
your sequencing you have 12 reads
between one and six reads of gene two
and this is now a ratio of two to one
you basically go well like what happened
here so originally started with three to
two but now you're two to one and the
problem is is that during library prep
there are amplification biases and also
during sequencing there can be sequence
biases as well so to work around that if
you incorporate unique unique molecular
indices into your library prep basically
each individual molecule is tagged with
its own identifier and then the Chi C
kits we use a fully random 12 base
sequence that gives you nearly 17
million different combinations of um
eyes
and what this happens then during
analysis is that the reads are collapsed
based on the molecule counts
let's take a look at gene 1 and now look
at the small colored bars so while you
have 12 reads you basically have three
molecules you have four replicas two
molecule 1 3 multiplicative molecule 2
and five replicates of molecule 3 and
these reads then are collapsed into just
molecule 1 2 & 3 based off the UM is
then four gene - you have six reads but
only two molecules more copies of
molecule one and two copies of molecule
two and again these are collapsed just
into two molecules so when you account
for the um ice you then retain your
original 3 to 2 ratio
put this in practice here so the
assumption is is follow so if you have
fourfold delusions of RNA so 20
nanograms five nanograms in 1.25
nanograms and you amplify these the same
you should actually see fourfold
differences and reads
so on the left here we have when you
just map the raw reeds
so what you can see is is that actually
you have roughly speaking the same
amount of allocated reads per sample and
the reason is is that you are loading
equal molar amount onto your sequencer
so ultimately it will just be read all
about the same amount however when you
account for your um eyes you're now
removing any replicate reads and when
you remove the replicate reads you see
this expected fourfold drop in molecule
counts and collectively counting um eyes
delivers an accurate representation of
your starting RNA amount this is a
typical workflow that can be performed
with target and RNA library prep so you
start with your total RNA and then you
perform C DNA synthesis just a standard
RT reaction and in step one you perform
a primer extension in um my assignment
basically having a gene specific forward
primer with a unique molecular index
following a clean up you then perform a
first stage of PCR this is a target
specific amplification with a gene
specific reverse primer and this also
contains a Universal sequence following
a beat cleanup you then perform a second
state to PCR which enables you to
perform library amplification as well as
sample index assignment and this is
performed using primers that target
universal regions added during the to a
stage target specific amplification
reaction
all right so now let's shift gears here
and move to the small world to looking
at the micro RNA sequencing so if you
look at some current challenges of micro
RNA there was a requirement for
inconvenient sample amounts so
traditional small RNA seek it's require
up to one microgram of sample input and
may not be ideal with lower RNA input
amounts and this is problematic because
there's a lot of effort focused on micro
RNA sequencing from bio fluids and as a
result this requirement basically
renders older kits not compatible or
optimized the second problem is poor
data quality so on target RNA micro RNA
NGS account for only about twenty to
thirty percent of your total reads and
often this is okay however
the traditional kits were only mapping
20 to 30-percent when it should have
been about 60 to 70 percent part of the
problem was that adaptive dimers are the
bane of every micro RNA researchers
existence
so these eat away at your read budget
they are very small they're
preferentially amplified into
preferentially sequenced as a result
what you had to do was perform gel band
excision and also one point is that bio
fluids may be contaminated with similar
sized RNAs and overall there was a lot
of tedious nature with micro RNA
sequencing so gel based workflows can
take multiple days and this becomes very
problematic with a large number of
samples
what we've developed is the KY seek
micro RNA kit it's compatible with
Illumina sequencers and as of a couple
weeks ago it's actually compatible with
ion torrent sequencers as well you can
perform differential expression and
novel micro RNA discovery what
distinguishes this kit basically it's a
gel free rapid workflow you heard it
there its gel free and so what I'd like
to say if you're interested in sort of
the you know the retro style science and
you want to be like somebody's in the
1980s performing scientific research
certainly stick with your gel based
approach but if you want the most rapid
clean way to make a micro RNA library
trick I seek micro RNA this can be done
whether you have one nanogram or 500
nanograms of input and with whatever
type of sample you have whether serum
plasma bio fluid cells or tissues
interestingly we've also minimized the
presence of hy4
Y RNA and you may say well why would you
do that and the answer is that in serum
and plasma hy4 is over-represented up to
70 percent or more and basically it's
the same size as a micro RNA so without
eliminating it it basically eats up all
of your read budget now a tip I have
here is that micro RNA sequencing
actually works for any small RNA that
has a 5 prime phosphate it is
approximately 50 base pairs or less so
if you're interested in tRNA fragments
or PI RNAs or other small rnas in that
general size frame micro RNA sequencing
will work for you
here's the workflow UI gate adapters to
the three prime end and the five prime
end of the micro RNA and we add unique
molecular indices during reverse
transcription and this RT primer
basically targets the three prime
adapter at this stage two is where the
chi seek it eliminates adapter dimers
from the library
following a cdna cleanup we then perform
library amplification so here I have
represented where we index with a single
index and at the time of this putting a
slide together which is again only a
couple weeks ago we had 48 indices now
we actually just released a 96 index kit
so if you're on the line and listening
and you want more than 48 indices let me
know and we can have a conversation
about it
and just as a note this is the style of
BA that you will routinely see with the
KY seek my chronic it this is one single
nice sharp peak or your micro RNA sized
library
okay so looking at one piece of data
compared to a competitor get what I have
here is a page gel after a standard
library prep protocol so this is the Chi
Sigma karna kit a single sharp band and
what this allows you to do is go
straight to the sequencer now for
competitor 1 and 2 you do have that nice
micro RNA band however it's very faint
and it's about the same intensity as ad
adapter dimer also there's larger weight
and lower weight contaminants as a
result you would need to perform a gel
excision prior to sequencing
so for this experiment we did perform
that gel excision on competitor 1 and
sequenced the against the kaisi kit so
what you see is about 375 reads with
competitor 1 but with a Chi C kit you
actually see more than 600 micro rna's
with greater than 5 mapped reads to go
okay well it's pretty nice that's 200
more micro rna's the even cooler thing
is that if you look at the experimental
setup we used only 100 nanograms for chi
seek micro RNA in 1 microgram for
competitor 1 so we actually use 10 fold
less input and still got 200 more micro
rna's
okay so another shifting of gears here
so what you'll see is that there's a lot
to consider when you're working with RNA
NGS and this is something to you know I
would recommend downloading the
recording and listening to this a couple
of times and certainly we're always here
as a resource for you so we have a new
kit called coyote qpx and that stands
for ultra flexing your NGS gene
expression basically we have this for a
3 prime transcript 'm as well as a 3
prime targeted RNA it works for samples
whether you have 1 to 100 bells and it's
basically a direct lysis method and it
also works for very low RNA inputs so 10
pika grams to one nanogram and basically
we are tagging each of these samples
during C DNA synthesis
to show this a little bit more how we do
this is that we use plates of anchored
all go DT primers that have the
following structure you have the anchor
you have the all go DT and then you have
the umi sequence so again this is a
twelve base fully random umi and every
well has its own unique cell ID so a
96-well plate has 96 unique IDs and the
384-well plate has a 384 unique cell IDs
and what's really cool about this
workflow is that after reverse
transcription you can combine an entire
plate worth of cDNAs into one tube so if
you have even up to 96 or 384 samples
you actually only have to perform one
ultimate library prep but what's even
cooler is that if you want to have like
hundreds of samples or dozens of plates
you can actually tag each of those and
when you incorporate your traditional
library ID you can do say 48 sample IDs
at times the 96 cell ID or 48 sample
like these times the 384 ID and do
thousands of libraries
alternatively if you want this just
because you do a small number of
libraries but want to still multiplex it
you only even have to do eight
transcript downs at the time so
basically whatever type of throughput
you have this solution can work for you
showing this a little bit differently so
basically take this 96-well plate and
look closely at it with a magnifier and
this is an individual well from the
plate so you have your cDNA you have
your poly tea you have your view of mine
you have your cell ID and basically
every well again has its own unique
Belle ID and what this enables you is
after arti you put everything in a
single tube and perform your remaining
reactions in library prep
we have library prep done let's move in
to sequencing so first off there's often
the discussion about what read lengths
are recommended that will give you some
recommendations here for stranded
targeted and micro RNA but certainly if
you have questions of what else you
should be doing particularly say with
upx you can email me but very nicely to
and all of the hydrogen kits we put the
recommended read structures in the
handbooks so for stranded RNA seek the
basic protocol is prepared in two by
seventy five and you can perform a two
by 150 if you're looking for novel
transcripts splice site variant splice
site isoforms etc for targeted RNA NGS a
single one by 150 is required and just
as a note other kits may be different so
for casing micro RNA we recommend a one
by seventy-five and this enables you to
sequence through the um ein other kits
recommend to one by 50 but they're a
little bit behind in that they don't
contain um eyes and if you're used to
only using a one by 50 and if you don't
care about using the um eyes with the
kaisi kitten you can still just use a 1
by 50 with a chi seek micro RNA kit
and as a tip always check weather kits
were require custom sequencing
restructures and/or custom indexing
primers
point is read allocation so for stranded
RNA NGS we touched on this earlier but
we'll talk about it again when you
select only for your mRNAs you need
about twenty to twenty-five million per
sample ribosomal depletion you need
about fifty million reads so looking at
targeted RNA NGS this is a value then of
a better usage of your read budget for
shallow reads you need about two
thousand reads per gene moderate five
thousand reason high coverage only about
fifty thousand about fifteen thousand
reads so again here if you have a small
panel you can make very efficient usage
of your read budget and for micro RNA
NGS a general catch-all is about five to
eight million per sample for your FFPE
and difficult fluids we recommend 10 to
20 million and for fresh and frozen less
than 5 million
so a couple tips here the kids with um
eyes can help you optimize your read
allocation by revealing the amount of
read replication okay so if you're
performing RNA NGS and you're reading
every molecule 50 times that means
you're basically over sequencing your
sample and then in subsequent
experiments you can back off of your
read allocation per sample and make more
efficient use of it tip 2 is I always
like to over sequence particularly when
you're working with tough samples like
FFPE or difficult fluids cerebrospinal
fluid or cell culture media and actually
quite difficult to sample so it's always
best to allocate as much reads as you
can tip 3 the number of samples that you
can multiplex depends on your
application your sequencer and your
reagent cartridge now I know sometimes
this goes without saying but importantly
make sure that you know all the moving
parts when you're considering what
number of samples to sequence together
for example my seek is great sequencer
but you only have about 30 million reads
so if you have 10 FFPE samples
probably it's best to use a sequence
with a higher capacity such as a neck
seek
and another recommendation involves the
amount of library to load on your
sequencer and here we'll just look at
aluminum instruments and as a note up
front
ultimately the optimal amount may need
to be empirically determined however
some basic guidelines are that for the
tie seek stranded nine peak mole on the
peak molar on my seek one six one point
six picomolar on the neck seat and for
both IOC targeted RNA NGS and micro no
NGS we recommend 10 pica molar or 1.2
picomolar and again all sequencers are
slightly different even if you have
optimized your amount of loading and you
then move to a second sequencer all
sequencers are slightly different and be
sure to find your sweet spot for the
loading and err on the side of caution
move into analysis and a preference the
analysis with I'm a bench scientist so
typically speaking my expertise is in
RNA extraction library prep and
sequencing and why I say that upfront is
is that the analysis can often be a
tricky thing so what I always typically
look for is prepackaged analysis
solutions that basically enable you to
move your lack of expertise aside and
allow the bioinformatics experts to
analyze your data and a lot of times you
can actually do this on your own using
pre-designed
pipelines
so for stranded RNA NGS we recommend the
CLC bio medical genomics workbench and
basically it allows you to analyze and
visualize data from all major NGS
platforms and here we have a workflow
picture of CLC at the bottom there's
basically ready to use workflows for all
types of analysis whether you're looking
for whole genome sequencing whole exome
sequencing targeted sequencing whole
transcriptome sequencing even micro RNA
sequencing their pre-designed workflows
and for people like me that don't have a
bioinformatics expertise to design your
own pipeline these are very very
favorable in addition to CLC for
targeted and micro RNA NGS we also have
a couple free analysis packages through
the gene globe data analysis Center
and looking at this as one example for
micro RNA basically you upload the data
and then the data analysis is performed
for you and this is available at caged
and conformed slash gene globe and what
this site does is it performs daftar
trimming read mapping and um i counting
and it's very much as easy as uploading
your files and clicking start
receive is a variety of outputs of your
data you have a summary tab that gives
you important mapping metrics for the
sequencing run you have a micro RNA PI
RNA tab which basically gives you the
entire list of microRNAs that were found
as well as their um accounts as well as
the recount in addition we do this for
other RNAs and not characterize mapable
not characterized mapable is basically a
tab that you can use if you want to look
for novel potential micro RNAs and again
what we're giving you is a list of the
sequence list of the genomic coordinates
as well as the UM eye and the recounts
and from there you can take this
information and basically start the
assessment of whether it is a real micro
RNA or not
following primary analysis we also have
secondary analysis and secondary
analysis is your differential expression
analysis there's a variety of ways to
normalize your data including G norm
total molecular tag counts dc2 and
trimmed mean of em and basically get a
fold regulation output
for tertiary analysis we have the
ingenuity pathway analysis basically
it's asking what's next by modeling
analyzing and understanding complex
omics data sets and what I like to think
of it is is that it is a very much
automated pubmed system break it down
basically into its roots okay so what IP
a does is that it collates and collects
and quality assures all basically
publications and data sets that are
deposited into the public database and
it integrates them together and provide
you connections to all of your papers
okay so instead of manually looking
paper by paper by paper by paper it
basically if you upload your data set it
integrates this into the IPA set and
basically weaves it into what already is
exists in what is known for the data set
we also have the omec soft erase studio
and basically you can go from fast queue
to insight and data processing is
performed in the omec soft array studio
and you can move from fast queues fescue
to your differential gene expression
analysis
in addition if you look at IPA and
analyses of omics often lands datasets
and we'll go over that in a minute on
the omics off side you have processing
curation and QA of hundreds of thousands
of RNA seek samples integrated into the
omics soft lands and these would be your
uncle and in your diseased land with
more than eight thousand comparison
datasets as I already mentioned you have
your journal articles and any positive
any deposited datasets into public
datasets and you have curated findings
integrated into IPA so when you combine
omics soft with IPA you can have the
biological analysis of each of your data
set and comparison of your analysis to
all of the omics soft analysis so
basically you take your data and you do
the tertiary analysis it gives you
what's already known what's potentially
unknown and literally gives you a built
in future direction for your experiment
and a quick look at array lands this is
basically where you can store manage
search and visualize basically any of
your data you can analyze millions of
genomic samples across multiple
platforms and there is also hosted data
content including uncle land disease
land in genetics land but you can also
have your own privately customer built
lands
all right so let's finish up here we'll
take a quick look at genomic services
and first question is always why genomic
services basically genomic services does
all the difficult parts for you so if
you don't have the time or you don't
have the resources to do your
experiments have the experts do them so
we have unique access to Rd and
manufacturing and there's labs and
either hild in Germany or Frederick
Maryland importantly there's also access
to the innovative kaijin technologies
and never underestimate that there's
always consultation and guidance
available from lab scientists that are
actually conducting your experiments in
addition you have access to people like
me that have built the NGS kits and also
my colleagues that have built the qPCR
kits built the sample prep kits built
the automation etc
- what types of services does the
genomics group provide they provide
sample preparation services library
preparation services Sanger seek
services qPCR services custom services
in the now in addition they also perform
data analysis and interpretation so here
we have Explorer RNA which is a custom
built pipeline for the genomic core
analyses they also have access to a
biomedical workbench PLC genomics
workbench IV a as well as IPA so we went
over IPA and basically what the genomics
core can do is your entire sample prep
your library prep your primary analysis
your secondary differential expression
analysis as well as ultimately your
tertiary analysis
so looking at again what is provided for
RNA specifically there's RNA isolation
from a variety of samples mRNA
sequencing and micro RNA seek whole
transcriptome as well as targeted RNA
analysis
and for reporting and data analysis
we've already touched on this but you
receive a comprehensive final report
that's easy to read and it summarizes
all of your results and as well you have
a follow up call that is built in to
discuss your analysis as well as any
next steps and sometimes I might I might
even be on that call just depends on
sort of what type the next steps are so
we can give you additional
recommendations
so in summary here we'll go back to our
pyramid of NGO success so if you look at
when NGO success depends on depends on
your sample source the quality matters
so when you're looking for your samples
you want to be sure that your sample
material is tightly controlled and
homogeneous across your entire study
this is particularly important when
working with bio fluids so you want to
be sure that safe perhaps your
collection technique is consistent
across your entire portfolio of samples
one step up is your sample so you want
to be sure that your type of sample is
tailored to your experiment so cells
tissues FFPE and biofluids body fluids
is an interesting thing so a lot of
times one of the most easily accessible
samples is a whole blood sample however
whole blood has quite a high background
of signal present simply because you
have blood cells so if you're looking
for a circulating signature you want to
often
set aside your whole blood sample and
process it into a serum or a plasma
sample and look basically for yourself
free RNAs extraction kit is the third
level you want to be sure that you
choose a kit that gives you flexibility
flexibility in terms of both meeting the
needs of your experiment but also
keeping in mind what's next for your
experiment so say you have this awesome
whole transcriptome analysis finding and
your IPA analysis suggests that
particular micro RNAs are regulated with
it and you did just a large RNA prep now
you have to go back and Reax tracked a
look at your micro RNA so again here
choose an extraction kit that gives you
the entire gamut of RNA from your
smaller nate to your large RNA library
kit library kit depends on your intended
application and regardless when you're
performing any beat cleanups or size
selections etc be sure to remove all
traces of ethanol ethanol is a killer of
downstream enzymatic reactions and in
addition to killing the downstream
reaction it also increases your adapter
dimers so yay
not only have you killed your real
product you've also increased your
background product so just be sure that
everything is ethanol free sequencing
pay attention to your details pay
attention to your read allegation pay
attention to your read structure pay
attention to your amount of library that
is loaded to your sequencer and finally
analysis is of paramount importance you
can have these excuse me you can have
the best quality samples the best
isolation kit the best libraries
and if the analysis is bad everything is
stuck and you can't reach ultimate NGS
success so be sure to perform proper
primary secondary analyses and also keep
in mind your tertiary analyses enables
you to add the layer of biological
interpretation
okay so with that I think we'll take any
questions I certainly appreciate you
taking the time today to listen to us
and feel free to ask any questions and
also feel free to write down my email
Jonathan dot Schaefer at Chi Cheng calm
I freely give out my email simply
because here at gaijin one of our goals
is to give you what you need for your
experiments so if you need help in
setting up your experiments or help in
determining what isolation kit or what
library kit you need send me an email in
addition we also have expert technical
scientist at kaijin and you can contact
technical support at ichon as well so
with that we'll finish up thanks a lot
thank you dr. Schaefer for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started our first
question is when performing
transcriptome sequencing do you
recommend mRNA enrichment or ribosomal
depletion
that's a great question Judy so if it
comes down to what you're interested in
if you're interested in mRNAs only I
would recommend mRNA enrichment so
basically select for your rnas that have
a polyadenylated site but that being
said if you're interested in long
non-coding rnas as well I would
recommend bribe assemble depletion the
final point is that for heavily
fragmented samples like FFPE samples
sometimes the poly a tail is lost so as
a result it's better to perform
ribosomal depletion instead of relying
on potentially missing a target because
the tail is no longer there
thank you because kyochon offer a
ribosomal depletion kick that's a good
question so we actually are just
launching a kit right now it's called
Caius eat fast select it's a single step
ribosomal depletion kit you basically
add avery agent to your RNA and ramp
down temperature for 20 minutes and it
eliminates either your ribosomal RNA or
your globin RNA does the Chi seek micro
RNA kit work with serum or plasma
um it works with both and this is an
area this is a great question to ask
because a lot of effort with micro rna's
with serum or plasma now I often get
asked also whether serum or plasma
should be used and basically whatever
you have access to as long as it's all
serum or all plasma so I wouldn't
recommend working in comparing serum to
plasma just because they are inherently
prepped differently and how much
starting material do you recommend
typically speaking we start with 200
microliters of serum or plasma
comfortably you can go down to 100
microliters mildly uncomfortably you can
go down to even 25 microliters but all
things being equal I would start with um
200 microliters and if you're working
with exosomes I would probably start
with one milliliter just because the
amount of RNA should be even much lower
because you're looking at a sub
compartment
thank you so we have time for one more
question do you have to do a full plate
of samples for KFC qpx can use a portion
of the plate um that's a good question
as well so in the time we've released
this kit this question has came up
repeatedly so I'm glad this was asked
and the Vic I see qpx kit you can you
have to use only minimally eight wells
of the plate and what this allows you to
do is that you can basically just use a
portion of the plate and the plate is
actually a breakable plate so you can
literally crack off a column of wells
and just perform a transcriptome
analyses at one time or you can perform
24 you can perform 96 so gives you quite
a bit of flexibility to efficiently work
through your samples
very good I would like to once again
thank dr. Schaefer for his presentation
I would also like really appreciate it
oh you're welcome I would also like to
thank hydrogen for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 11th
2019 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please show
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon
goodbye